Imagine those big ass cutters on a T-Rex.
That's true.
Wow.
What a man.
We're in the volume to 200.
This game doesn't get age restricted.
Peepers peak as a streamer right here.
This is, everything's gonna go downhill.
Hello, everybody.
Hello, Harlem.
I am not intimidated at all.
this i could talk to women with double d's we had the usual
the battle royale uh selection of what games i'll be playing
this week i got tricked into putting that into the selection
of games that we're gonna we're gonna fight it out because i
thought i was talking about like dino crisis and like dino
shooter games and then someone was like you should check out
dd dinosaur with double d's And I was like, that sounds like
a shooter.
That sounds like an FPS game since I was on the topic of FPS
games and shooters.
And then all of us looked it up on Steam and we finally
realized what the double Ds mean.
My head doesn't even cover up.
Now it's just D dinosaur with 1D.
Wow.
Oh my god, she has two, she's carrying two volleyballs on
her, guys.
All right, use a headset for the best experience.
Tidosaur with double D.
People are ready to lose Sean.
Oh my god.
We lost our Thanos with double Ds.
How could we, how could we, how could this happen?
And I still didn't get age restricted.
my god the dinosaurs what an ass too that's
so true all the fat rotted away we never knew the true size
it's like what if they had other others like cows oh my he's
not it's not lying though others on a T-Rex.
True.
What about the asshole?
Who's gonna represent the ass?
How could we have been so ignorant to mislook such an
important detail in life and history oh my god these guys
are pioneers millions of years later what is this we're
learning about history right now we're learning about
dinosaurs dd dinosaur looks around the room while moving her
knees up and down nervously she anxiously look around the
unfamiliar room her eyes wide open it's an old musty room
just like in the movies this is the history channel it's
like the one where about the aliens a therapy room so
stereotypical that almost seems to be a parody she can't
help but be a little bit nervous wait do i look presentable
enough oh wait are you sure they're d's that's why couldn't
science be like this when i was in school she hears a mature
hand confidently push down the handle the door to the office
that must be the doctor wow what a man she looks slowly
looks him up and down from head to toe a voice like a
subwoofer arms like a true turn the volume to 200 she can
hardly focus on what leon is seeing while her mind wanders
I've never kissed someone with a mustache before.
I wonder what that would feel like.
Get it together, DD dinosaur.
What is wrong with you?
You're normally not like this.
Come, let's have a look.
Impatiently, he goes through...
He looks like Omni-Man.
Wait, that's literally Omni-Man.
I mean, you just need him to turn around and start twerking.
you feel a bit confused is that correct before dd dinosaur
has a chance to answer he continues sorry what was your name
again uh stop
why was there a timer to type my name api anglin yeah ap i'm
taking ap studies right out.
Why is naming myself a quick time event?
I am distracted by Omni Man right now.
DD Dinosaur with double Ds.
Oh, nice.
I must admit, I am quite nervous.
Oh, I'm playing a shooter game right now.
Don't worry, there's FPS later.
There's no need to be nervous.
This is just an interview to get to know each other a bit
because the more I know you the easier it will be for me to
help you this is why we're going to do an introduction test
first so that if you turn out to be dumb like a stupid bitch
I know if I should talk to you in a condescending tone in
the future
right or wrong answer in this initial interview.
Are we sure this is a real doctor?
Do you not see the degrees on his desk right now?
Look at all those degrees behind him.
Look at that.
He has trope.
Oh my god.
He is proud of it.
A doctor can have hobbies.
Deity dinosaur is a little nervous.
but not as determined towards leon all right time for the
first question in the few words how you describe yourself
i'll be i'm pretty hilarious insecure anxious oh i'm i'm so
insecure about my double d's i feel like they're a bit too
small leon takes a good look at her
can understand that i'm so humble i'm so humble i anywhere
next question name something you really enjoy all right
let's see oh yes i love a man that looks like a vilter mite
oh oh wait
This was the easiest, sir, this is not professional.
Sir, sir, this is not professional.
Patient, doctor here.
This is an HSHR violation.
No way.
Oh, by the way, I almost forgot.
What is your favorite dinosaur?
Wait, what is she?
Oh, no.
Honestly, would he ask that question?
Did he die as they start sweating between your sensual
thighs and underneath their breasts?
This was a mistake.
I never should have came here.
Oh, wait.
I have to answer.
I heard somebody come across even more suspicious.
Um, T-Rex!
T-Rex?
Hmm.
Okay, your answer.
Very peculiar.
With a questionable look on his face.
Dr. Leon turned his attention to his notes.
All right.
All done.
Believe it or not, those answers can teach you a lot about a
person.
Everybody's favorite dinosaur is the T-Rex.
And I, as a therapist, have already gotten to know a lot
about you.
My favorite dinosaur changed after watching this stream.
for today.
I was just making new appointment for next week so we can
really get into it.
Alright, that sounds good, doctor.
Please calm me, Leon.
Oh, I did.
I finished day one.
That was a strange day, Mr. Robson.
They're usually my only conversation partner.
But today I was sharing the most personal opinions with this
random, racked a stud.
Well, there he is.
You're so sweet and cute.
She tickles his cute little cat.
Don't think you're doing your cat.
Guys, what a normal day.
Do not your cat.
On the other hand, there come the point I wish you would be
inevitable to share the real reason that I'm visiting.
him my loneliness I've been lonely for millions of years now
she lets out a sad sigh no it's just so hard to have such
small boobs I know thankfully I have you mr.
Robson please mr.
Robson don't get political what did he say he's like I don't
think dinosaurs her fright.
Do I really know for sure that I want to go through with
this?
It all feels so vulnerable.
She arrived early, so she doesn't feel like she had to go in
right away.
But despite her hesitation, the clock on the wall seems to
be ticking faster and louder than usual.
Maybe I'm making a mistake by coming here.
Don't worry, the shooter part, it's an FPS game.
It's going to come up soon, guys.
Bullets are in the booth.
Then, Didi Dinosaur noticed the overly attractive man that's
sitting just a few seats away from From the corner of her
eyes, BD Dinosaur sneaks a peek his way.
When she sees him, she can barely believe he is real.
A jawline that seems to have been chiseled by a sculptor.
A hairline that could break off a hedge trimmer.
And that body, wow.
As if his place of birth is dreamland.
He doesn't even seem to notice me.
He must think I'm a monster.
Is my boobs too small?
up some courage and Ashley decides to speak to him.
Huh?
A cat owner, I see.
He looks up.
Hmm?
Oh, I don't like being next to it.
Deity dinosaurs taking back while easy is for her to talk to
his attractive stranger.
It's normally never this easy for me.
She looks her way around in her purse.
It must be here somewhere.
Here it is.
What?
Why did...
Is that triceratops?
Like, she can top you anytime if you know what I mean.
Didi Dancer hands in one of those cat hair rollers.
Oh, whoa, no problem.
Rawr.
Oh,
oops.
Tiny growl to assert my dominance.
Just a small growl.
Oh, bless you.
A relaxation test?
Yes, this often helps people calm the chaos and busyness in
their heads, which in theory should make communicating about
problems easier.
Didi Das, or looks again Dr. Leon's strong fingers that look
like they could be world-heavy weight-thumb wrestling
champions.
I hope this relaxation test is a massage.
We will try to achieve this through a massage.
skis before.
Jackpot.
Okay, please lie down.
He gestures to the couch in the corner of his office.
Oh my god.
She bears her neck flies down on the table.
Splashing her colossal slambers onto the table.
No, don't do this to me.
How is there?
Could you maybe?
Oh my god.
Oh!
Move your hands.
No, don't do.
Don't wait.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Guys, this might be over.
No.
Why?
We just won't fly away.
No.
You failed.
us.
You did great.
Devour it.
I'm doing it.
She said he said I did great.
I'm in.
A dinosaur eyes aren't very good.
But they can detect movement.
When Leon puts his pen away, she strikes.
Oh!
Game over!
I ate Leon, but I was so hungry.
Are you comfortable and ready?
I'll do a victory dance.
I'll show her how quirky I am.
Oh my...
She's so quirky.
I thought she was gonna do a four-night dance.
I...
This was an intense session.
So, I think we did more than enough for today.
He remarks as he takes some notes like a doctor would do.
Oh, and by the way.
Before you go, I notice you're talking to an attractive man
out there in the waiting room.
And while I'm not allowed to share anything personal about
him, due to Dr. Patient confidentiality, I would still like
to advise you to be cautious when talking to him.
That's all.
Be cautious?
That's strange.
I didn't get the impression I couldn't trust them at all.
All right, bedroom.
I'm back with Mr. Robert.
Mr. Robson lies down on his back.
It's a way to tell D.D.
Diasso to stroke his chubby belly.
Hello, cats don't like their belly rub.
So this means he really trusts me.
It's so cute.
Look, maybe she actually puts steroids in his food, baby.
Meow.
Robeson behave.
Besides, I'm...
Week three, waiting room.
For a minute, she thinks about the possibilities of today's
test.
Hopefully one day.
I would be in pregnancy.
Okay.
I don't think a therapist does that, guys.
Hey, dinosaur.
Dinosaur?
What?
How does he know?
How?
Dinosaur.
These guys are really fizzling ourselves getting red hot and
stressed so that she feels like it's hard to breathe.
As if her juicy throat is being squeezed tight.
How do you know that?
Your name?
I heard overheard Dr. last we remember we gotta eat him
quick quick eat him the name's hunk i've heard worse hunk
i've heard worse but you just have to think about it like
this at least your name is so cute that's up i got him dd
dinosaur with big knockers come in it's time for your
appointment oh my god Oh, we're getting so close, guys.
He even gave me a nickname.
For today, I prepared a coordination test.
A coordination test?
What does that entail?
Doctor, would you mind if I take off my shoes for a moment?
Leon looks up and surprised, and then shyly nods in
agreement.
Look, it's like the shoes are cutting my circulation, guys.
I can't concentrate.
Oh, wow.
What are you doing?
Oh, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Wow.
Welcome, everyone.
this great day of football today it's dinosaur versus dr
leon and as the whistle blows we'll find out how this match
will go as there is some definite tension there between the
two here we go oh my god oh where's the keep are still there
get out here there we go yeah come on
DD dinosaur Oh DD dinosaur
Nice DD dinosaur is exhausted and flopped into her bed
without showering Her legs spread open Oh she's man
spreading So her feet are soft DD dinosaur is lying bed with
Mr. Robson Snuggled warmly against her He tries to wash her
Eat butt.
Okay, I will say, I can tell what kind of fetish the devs
have right now.
You can tell.
I know it's very subtle, chat.
It's very subtle.
Mr. Robinson is okay.
Just doing what cats do, guys.
He's just doing what cats do.
Is licking his anus with great precision.
Look, he's trying to clean himself, guys.
So it has to stay up your stress level.
I'd first like to take another memory test today.
Don't be intense.
Just answer you some questions.
Do you think you can handle that?
Wait, what test was it again?
I'm so funny.
Next question.
What was the color of your sweet cat?
It was red.
It was pink.
What is wrong with me?
How did I forget?
Do you also happen to know?
What the color my belt is.
Oh my god.
I can't seem to remember very well.
Is it okay to feel it to refresh my?
Sure, you can.
Oh It was none of these wait a minute Maybe I should feel
it.
Oh, I'm so smart.
I'm so fucking smart
This time up here he dies and then she's oh And grips it
tightly.
What?
What are you doing?
I swear to you guys, this...
If this game doesn't get age restricted...
I swear.
If you're reading this...
Unfortunately, I'm no longer alive.
No!
Mr. Robson!
Tears well up in her eyes!
As she desperately tries to come up with a solution.
A solution that does not exist.
Will you ask me to prepare another physical test?
I think you're right.
It's high time.
Here we go.
Oh, shit.
I knew it was DDI.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
I What the fuck I'm gonna lock in guys for DD dinosaurs
Where is G?
Oh my god, who adds numbers?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god I can't even look at this
dance because I'm trying I'm trying to lock oh my god I
don't have F12 that's fine Okay, oh my god, what?
A,
F, G, please.
I didn't even get to see what she took up.
I, who did she take up?
I'll never go.
No, I was so locked in.
I was trying so hard.
why is it so evil please sit down dd dinosaur while i was
eavesdropping on you guys just now i couldn't help but
overhear that you have a date with hunk tonight huh he knows
um yeah right but it's all because he wasn't honest before i
mean it was all because of a misunderstanding last week leon
noticed her slip of tongue he wasn't honest i told you to
watch out for him wasn't that big of a deal.
It looks down concerned for a moment.
He's mad.
He's jealous.
He didn't get the chance.
He had so many chances.
Now you're too late, Leon.
Please watch yourself.
The only thing she's currently watching tensely is the
half-beared photo of Leon.
Oh, I noticed that on day one.
Don't worry, Diddy Dinosaur.
Are you trying to get me drunk or something?
She says teasingly as she takes a big sip.
Again, she takes a big sip of her drink and notice that she
starting to feel a little light-headed.
Oh, wait, dance.
Wait, I want to dance, though.
Didi-Dazzer is going for it.
I remember the dance.
Oopsie.
What in the world am I doing now?
You do realize that was a non-alcoholic drink, right?
It was literally a glass of orange juice for a moment.
She thinks about what she would do if, like, we're lying
next to her right now.
You voted for this hunk, him bros.
There, this is your reward.
Why is he not here?
Did I say something wrong?
She suddenly hears a familiar voice.
But wait.
Is that...
Hunk?
His voice sounds muffled.
It's hard to hear what he's saying.
But he sounds emotional.
I hope he's doing okay.
He sounds worried.
This is suddenly a startle.
She hears the madly low voice of Dr. Leon react angrily at
hunk.
Wow, that doesn't sound like one of his usual sensual
sessions.
Didi Dinosaur tries not to listen out of respect, but still,
it's very curious.
I shouldn't get involved in this.
It's probably just one of Leon's tests, which are always
entertaining for some reason.
looks up his prize.
Wait.
What's that?
My name?
Did I just hear my name during their argument?
I don't pay you a doubt.
I'm paying...
I'm paying you to keep her here?
Without me, she wouldn't even be here right now.
T.D.
Dinosaur has a confused blank stare on her face.
She can't understand it.
He really is on the And...
He was a paid actor?
He betrayed you.
I'm sorry.
All those things you said to me?
Well, no.
In the end, it wasn't.
I...
I'm sorry I lied to you.
No, I didn't want it this way.
It's the FPS section, guys.
We waited for this moment.
We're finally getting the FPS part of the game oh my but do
it you have merry christmas you filthy animal i told you
finally the fps part i told you guys it was an fps game i
told we waited for this moment wait those tests your name
leon but you introduced yourself as Lena an anagram for a
paleontologist Oh fuck It was under our noses This entire
time I can't quite see who it is But Dr. Leon already sees
it What?
How is this possible?
Mr. Robson
Leon is dead.
Mr. Robeson.
None of us could have predicted this.
This.
The plot twist after plot twist after plot twist.
Yeah, whatever, dude.
Just kiss me.
Maybe we do the cat.
Maybe we do.
Maybe a cat is fine.
But she hears Robeson's romantic declaration of love.
Oh my god.
remember right here this is everything's gonna go downhill
i'll never find a game that will ever live up to its
expectations this should have been a game of the year
contender right here i feel like my life has changed forever
i don't know like how i can even go on after that like i
will never live that high again of dd dinosaur with double
d's i don't think any game will ever live up to that It was
truly life-changing.
I went, yeah, I went through a metamorphosis.
I feel like I've changed as the person playing this game.
We did it, Dragons.
It was a journey.
It was quite a journey with all of you.